what is up everybody it's anna mac and
welcome to another episode of the week's
best anime videos which is a weekly
newscast about the anime community on
YouTube the links are in the description
recommendations go in the comments now
as you may know we have a podcast on
this channel called Rand cafe which we
stream live every thursday at five p.m.
eastern standard time and during the
last Rand cafe after arguing for the
tenth time about who is best girl
between the RAM and Amelia we decided to
finally have it out to host a showdown
best girl showdown between Amelia and
REM we decided that this showdown will
be in the form of a live debate held
most likely on the channel of black
critic guy who is quickly becoming a
regular r & cafe member due to popular
demand so this is how it's going to go
down myself and briggs from alden anime
are going to be arguing that amelia is
in fact best girl and reesie row on the
other side black critic guy and anime
and recon are going to be arguing that
ram is best girl in our easy row we are
also going to have a neutral moderator
who is going to be making sure that we
are not just yelling over each other and
all of this is going to be happening
alive you're going to be able to come
and chat with us live and witness this
epic debate this epic showdown live now
we don't have an exact date yet but this
will be happening in the coming weeks so
stay tuned to our channels and stay
tuned to rant cafe for more information
forget UFC forget boxing forget the
Olympics this will be our super bowl we
will find out once and for all who is
best girl between RAM and Amelia and if
you want to get the conversation started
right now let me know in the comments
who you think is best girl but let me
know why you think that as well and for
those of you who want to be edgy and say
Felix's best girl i'm pretty sure
somebody already beat you to it but yeah
i'm really pumped for this it's going to
be amazing and while we're on the
subject of black critic guy this week he
actually uploaded a review for camino
Gnawa or your
name kimi no Gnawa has become the
highest-grossing animated film since
spirited away way back in 2001 and
although some news outlets are already
reporting that kimi no Gnawa is actually
the highest grossing film anime film of
all time when adjusted for inflation
kimi no Gnawa is still behind spirited
away by quite a bit at any rate i really
love this film myself and i really
enjoyed tony's review he is clearly a
big fan of the Creator makoto shinkai so
he appreciated the film and he looked at
it from a variety of angles so yeah
great review be sure to check it out
this week we had an interesting poll
come out and it was taken by 10,000
Japanese readers of char pedia this was
actually a poll about the most tear
jerking anime of all time and at first
place we had an Ohana followed by chrome
add your lie in April gintama and Angel
Beats personally I have to say that
these are really good choices I don't
know if I would have put clannad after
story may be ahead of an Ohana they're
definitely tied for my number one spot
but otherwise I can't disagree with
these choices and what about you what is
the one anime they made you most
emotional what is the most feared
jerking anime in your opinion let me
know in the comment and speaking of
people who cry like babies at the very
mention of an Ohana our good friend and
red cafe cast member mackerel not made a
hilarious parody video of code geass
this week in this video max counts down
some totally legit theories about what's
going to happen in code geass season 3
and the video is absolutely hilarious if
you're a code geass fan definitely check
it out and speaking of code geass we
recently uploaded a brand new code geass
video on this channel and we looked at a
piece of evidence that could indicate
that code geass season 3 was planned way
back in 2009 basically that are three
was planned all along if that is
something you find interesting you can
click the link below and this week we
also uploaded a news video about
everything we know so far about the
seven deadly sins season two so if
you're a seven deadly sins fan
definitely check that out our friend and
fellow ran cafe member Brynn from Bryn's
fandoms uploaded her first Q&A video
this week and it is definitely must see
entertainment now I wouldn't usually
a Q&A video in the week's best but Bren
did such a great job the video is so
funny and entertaining that you
definitely have to give it a watch and
be sure to check out her channel she's
awesome and here's my favorite and V for
this week okay my actual favorite AMV
for this week was a 5 centimeters per
second AMV called daylight by slayer AMV
5 centimeters per second is an older
film by makoto shinkai the creator of
Kamino Gnawa and I was definitely glad
to see that someone thought back to this
older film and created a new AMV for it
this week on top of that this MV is just
brilliant it combines great music with
the already amazing visuals from the
film and even though it is four and a
half minutes long which means it took a
lot of work it is worth every second a
great viewing experience and that's it
for this week guys if you like these
videos be sure to LIKE and subscribe and
if you want to be in touch with us on a
daily basis feel free to join our
discord server the link is in the
description and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]